hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gah and we're gonna watch some special
YouTube videos I haven't been exploring
the YouTube world that much lately just
been so self-consumed okay you know cuz
I mean get me why wouldn't I just want
to watch my videos all day you know
gosh I'm like compared to you I'm like
ridiculously good-looking I mean your
looks don't match mine whatsoever like
I'm the friend that he keeps around to
make himself look more attractive in
comparison and it totally works it
totally works cuz Lauren just oh I mean
look at her oh don't cry don't cry don't
cry is you look worse when you cook you
see me fry think so I cried during the
cash review oh yeah yeah all right cool
we've seen each other cry howling
animals are besties we're besties now ah
friends oh yes so they get away super
fast and I love the friend zone so much
so much rejection anyway
Oh watch a video called uh is a big one
called babymetal gimme chocolate oh my
god this sounds amazing I haven't seen
like a lot of these popular YouTube
videos but people Shogun's Rebecca
Black's Friday video you didn't I did I
showed him that yeah fried right that's
a good one
alright let's watch this wow it's gone
right give me chocolate that's expecting
Oh
they're Asian you might know them
say yes
that babymetal is the name
baby
wish I could dance like bed
ah
they speak another way
to do it
is that Virgin Mary behind
this isn't about anything Hoggett I'll
give me chocolate understand
all the bands of misery
taco later
I'm going to get essentials like a new
oh Jesus
now this makes sense them
Billy rocket on behind time
Oh
are they old enough for me to find
tracker
I can seriously see you being with this
girl
the monster spent yeah that's where we
could like shove each other around and
[__] you're been in a mosh pit no I I
came really close to being in one but
they look really painful
yeah that doesn't yeah it looks
uncomfortable I don't know why people do
that I have no ideas they're on drugs
yeah uh-huh that's it
um entertaining maybe first like minute
yeah cuz they're mainly just dancing
like very mediocre dancing yes and then
they kind of what all of these I mean
there are a variety of Asian girl bands
that usually they're not like this this
was like kind of a little bit heavy
metal and punk Rakesh usually they're
like like 50 girls in a group and
they're like oh yeah we're singing and
this is how they do it's like they look
pretty good me you did that actually
yeah there you go so that was that was
fun and new and interesting I mean I
don't really keep up with a lot of Asian
girl bands why not they're your people
they are my people you're so right Asian
jokes are the best that was a really
good job that was that was the best joke
I've ever told me laughing best joke
I've ever told right there yeah and I've
told a lot of jokes that one's the best
for sure
yeah I wonder of all their songs are
like that I hope so that style I hope so
they must be very tired people from all
the yeah that was like a lot of
high-energy dancing yeah they like ran
across the stage and ran back and if
they're doing a whole concert like that
like good for them cuz I like ran around
the block this morning and was like
catch a break get some water
really good I thought you're like a
really in shape person no I'm not in
shape at all yeah you are you're in
Gambia chair I say in a bikini and I was
like whoa damn kept that image in my
mind when I went home that night if you
know what I mean
masturbated I masturbated to you I could
guess that that's it yeah that's what I
was employing and then maybe I'll think
about these three girls but I got to
find out their age later to make sure
it's okay for me to think about them
I mean Asian people are usually older
than they look
that's true that's true Asian people age
very well I have I do have a friend in
Japan and she she's told me about the
Japanese girl bands and that it's
actually against the rules for any of
the girls in the band to have a
boyfriend because they are supposed to
keep this image of being available Wow
really
and there was this like big whole thing
about this one girl who was caught with
a man and they kicked her out of the
band and like everybody had this big
uproar and they'll also kick you out of
a band when you get too old this should
be the deal I make with all the girls on
the channel that they all have to be
single and that if they're caught with a
man or if they get too old you gotta
boot them out
you got to boot them out if they're not
gonna you know listen to the rules
[__] got to go [__] be [__]
alone can you come back here I feel
lonely without you it's okay I'm single
right now so I can be on the channel yes
she can
she can't don't worry guys nothing's
gonna happen with Lauren and I not my
decision
well thank you guys for telling me about
this video being out that was oh yeah
amusing if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe here and Lauren has her
own channel just past the hundred
subscribers 104 subscribe yo one I was
like I like for him yeah yeah right here
here yeah there you go Helsley
very soft arms thank you
Wow I've actually heard that before like
people have told me that I have soft
skin yeah well that doesn't make you any
more desirable at all I'm not one bit
God dad that rygan
we're gone I've been a subscriber since
you had two thousand subs that man's
voice where is she and keep up the good
work where is who
I don't know where is she you must have
friends this is my lowering dog
impression
Wow Wow sorry that was it was good
though was accurate
spot on spot on too good to be true it's
like I thought it was my my face yeah if
you close your eyes and you'd be like
Lauren's in the room yeah anyway good is
supposed to be about you um shout-out to
you buddy thanks for subbing this whole
time we must have 10 times more
subscribers than when you were a part of
the channel so thank you man yeah keep
seeing you
yeah you keep being you that's just spit
on you keep on you then oh come on if
you spit on me I would totally like that
as a compliment just go for just one
long spit and then I'll I'll clone it
and then program you to be into me
that's not gonna work we don't have I
can't yeah we don't have that technology
yet your joy from black do i watch
orphan black no what is that
it's a really really good TV show it's
about black orphans no okay without
clothes
well it's about clothes okay black
orphans sounded more interesting
Nathaniel davia Davila there's only 100
the Vila you said he's a riot bro I come
requesting a shout out I've been
subscribed to the real rejects for about
a month and I haven't regretted it yet
it's only been months so I mean it's
like really diminishes well thanks for
subscribing man okay that's not about me
how come none of these shout-out
requests are about me they're always
about somebody else guys if you if you
want Lauren to give you a shout-out sure
you just dude you to the shop I'm Lauren
Lauren no don't do that Lauren come on
the tamil didn't mean nothing by it I
mean he just really wants to have sex
with Veronica but you don't seem like
available you know you're kind of
intimidating that's why Nathaniel didn't
request you ma'am which it did Nathaniel
I have to deal with the [__] Matt didn't
can I have a shout out uh
yeah didn't you could totally have a
shout out what is didn't
and what if it's diamond it might be
dying in I'm sure he doesn't care how I
see it he should be so thankful and he's
getting a shout out at all exactly
exactly
the Matthews a good name one of the four
gospel names you know that book about
Christ
it's called bibley the bible' the bible'
that's how you pronounce it
biblic that is a correct Latin
pronunciation yeah bleh bible' yeah and
Jesus Christ is how you actually say his
name thank you
I've been wondering yeah yeah people get
confused some like Jesus Christ how so
white when you say it that way so silly
I know but Matthew you did a good job
writing that book for Christ he really
appreciates it
especially when he got the rights you
know for the film adaptation Passion of
the Christ Jesus made a lot of money on
that phone and so did you Matthew maybe
you've never seen Passion of the Christ
you mean you don't want to watch Jesus
get his ass kicked for two and a half
hours it's pretty awesome
Passion of the Christ is good for people
who like love Christ and want to
appreciate the suffering he did but if
you don't like Christ you'll also really
love it yeah that's right so so far
we've covered Asian racist jokes minor
black jokes and now Jesus jokes mm-hmm
this is good a little bit of pedophilia
a little bit of pedophilia and I could
see our demographic expanding right oh
god yeah how many more people can we
offend mm-hmm good night